joining us now with reaction is the
White House principal deputy press
secretary
Hogan Gidley Hogan thanks for joining us
really appreciate it
so you know I'm curious about your
proposal here from the White House to
move illegals into sanctuary cities due
to Flores by the way because we can't
detain more than 20 days families and I
want to make that clear
I'm curious I'd like your perspective on
it why aren't liberal governors and
mayors out there celebrating Hogan I
mean they've wanted them in their cities
they some of them are even proposing
they'll allow them to vote look we have
a crisis our southern border it's been
well documented on this show many times
Donald Trump predicted this Democrats
mocked and derided him when he said we
would see a record surge coming across
our southern border and here we are one
hundred thousand-plus last month alone
it is increasing on pace for over a
million this year and Democrats only
solution to this is to say let's make
everything that's illegal legal it's
completely ridiculous and so the
president said listen I understand where
you are you're not lifting a finger to
help protect American families at all
you say you want open borders Democrats
you say that illegal aliens have a right
to be here regardless of the costs so
you need to work with us our
administration and come up with a way
that we can transport illegal aliens
that are going to be released anyway
based on Democrat policies into your
communities and your districts in your
states that's the way it needs to be
done Democrats say they want them in
those cities and sanctuary cities which
are set up as sanctuaries for illegal
aliens they say they want it the
president said fine we'll put put your
money where your mouth is we're gonna
send them to your districts tell us when
and where to deliver them and we'll do
just that you know Hogan I find it
puzzling that the left is making a
legality argument on this in favor of
illegal immigration is this ironic I
mean is it as this escape the left and
one more thing I'd like to get your
opinion it was interesting who Leon
Castro did a town hall on another
network and he referred to this policy
as cruel and I did suggested earlier and
I'll continue to what what's
particularly cruel about it I mean it's
only cruel if you view illegal
immigration there's a burden am i
reading this wrong his words not mine by
the way you're absolutely right listen
they said
to attack our political opponents and
and that it was wrong for us to suggest
this wait a minute we're not attacking
anybody at the very least you should
have characterized it as an olive branch
to work with the Democrats you say
Democrats that you want all of these
illegal aliens to come into this country
unchecked we have to release them based
on the laws you put on the books and
that you won't change so that's fine
logically we would just work with you
because along the southern border dan
san san antonio san diego el paso yuma
we continue to release people into the
same communities it's a burden the folks
that don't work for government the
private organizations are telling us we
are overtaxed we can't do enough from
our charities to protect or help any of
these people we've got to put them in
other places across the country the
logical landing spot for so many of
these illegal aliens are the sanctuary
cities that Democrats say they love and
they say they want these people to come
into the country illegally and
unlawfully and they should go to those
places and we're just asking Democrats
we're here to help you out where do you
want them and we're happy to take them
there you know Hogan I know at times it
must feel like in the White House you
are you guys and ladies are out there on
an island that you're getting very
little help with regard to what should
have been a bipartisan issue just
establishing our borders but have the
Democrats proposed to you are they
working with the White House on any I
mean this any substantive proposal at
all to ensure that people who come into
the country just do it by our laws
anything at all you can put out for our
audience absolutely not I've heard no no
particular plan at all from Democrats
listen they are choosing to stand with
hundreds of thousands of people who pour
into this country illegally and
unlawfully as opposed to hundreds of
millions of American citizens they
cannot and will not address this issue
at all I guess it's just political
because Donald Trump's in the White
House and they think they can get these
people in the country and then get them
to vote for them one day but the fact is
we see human smuggling child smuggling
human trafficking the drug cartels they
control the southern border the
situation is so dire and so sad and
Democrats won't lift a finger to work
with the white house to protect our
people in the American communities but
also to stop this horrific practice of
using children to come into this country
illegally we've actually arrested or
busted up several child smuggling rings
in which they used the same child
multiple times to send them back to the
you know El Salvador and Honduras and
Guatemala to come back up they use them
multiple times it's such a tragic
circumstance down there and Democrats
won't do anything to stop it at all
everything they're doing incentivizes
more of this bad illegal behavior and
for the life of me I can't understand
why they won't do a thing to work with
this White House to protect American
communities their only solution is to
let everyone come in here not have a
southern border and release them into
your communities into your school
schools into your neighborhoods it's
unacceptable yeah it'sit's sad Hogan you
know the idea of enforceable borders
used to be bipartisan but I really
appreciate your time thanks a lot for
joining us tonight Hogan